well you've been watching the show you
know that college campuses are worse
than ever when it comes to free
expression and real tolerance especially
the tolerance for views that are right
to life
well take this exchange between a
student at Boston College and Kristin
Hawkins president of students for life
do you think that the children that are
apprehended at the border that are in
the US government care do you think like
babies who are going to die should be
resuscitated be given care do you
believe that like a baby who's born
alive during an abortion that Planned
Parenthood should get care joining me
now is Kristin Hawkins Kristen you
travel the country visiting college
campuses talking to students you really
kind of pointed out the you know it
illogical thinking is one thing it's
it's sad it's funny in a way but it's
very sad what happened next after that
well I actually asked her why she didn't
believe that babies who were born alive
during a failed abortion should be
allowed to live and she said well we've
already determined it's not a baby and
then she wanted to say I know you said
science but and so what she pointed out
was a cognitive dissidence we see all
the time on college campuses across the
country and I don't know whether or not
I changed her mind but I know she
certainly changed the minds of a lot of
pro-choice students who actually came to
the event to protest me I got to see
their eyes light up when she pointed out
the leftist hypocrisy on this issue
so again for people who missed it you
asked about children at the border right
should they be helped should they be
cared for infants yes a baby was born
despite an attempt to abort the baby
no but it's it's reflexive is it not
it's not like there's some deep moment
of reflection it's reflexive that's
right this is exactly they're just
repeating the talking points that they
hear and when they comes out of their
mouth when you force the other side to
actually say what it is what is their
advocating for it changes the minds of
everyone who's listening because they
realize this is this doesn't make sense
right this is illogical your humanity
should it be determined by the location
of your delivery room it is what have
you were at UCLA's campus about a year
ago tell us about that yes I've been to
UCLA I've been to Berkeley Harvard
Princeton all of these schools Dartmouth
and we have this conversation my tour is
called the lies a feminist tell and I
just tell women you know you're being
lied to by the abortion Lobby that tells
you you have to pay somebody else to
commit an act of violence against
someone weaker than you in order for you
to live your life as you see fit and
that's wrong that's actually
anti-feminist and what's the reaction
from is there I mean you're brave to be
doing this like you're a brave person I
just want to salute you for doing this
because I think a lot of young women I
said this on my radio show when you're
in your twenties especially when I was
much no one even thought it wasn't even
an issue back then people but now with
it with with the help of science digital
you know science techniques you could
see inside the womb now it was it the
person we were all you know speaking as
a former embryo we all speaking as a
former embryo we all were that's right I
think and Millennials the good news is
Laura the majority of our generation are
actually pro-life we're the largest
voting bloc now in America and we reject
those lies that the abortion industry
tells us he's saying unplanned DVC
unemploy absolutely we've sent thousands
of students to sound plan we actually
had a baby saved today in Indiana after
students once saw plan went and prayed
in front of the Planned Parenthood and
saved the life of a child oh my gosh
this is great great every life is
precious thank you so much for joining
us